Danny Masterson who's the actor from
That 70s Show has been sentenced to 30
years to life in prison
just a shockingly long prison sentence
uh he's 47 years old 30 years
plus 47 is not quite life in prison but
it's pretty close you're 77 when you get
out of there you're you're starting to
get up there when you're at 77. so I
read the allegations against him
and some people are saying they don't
even believe the allegations I basically
believe the women or at least I don't
see it much reason not to believe the
women broadly there are some
discrepancies I think between what they
alleged happened and what they are said
to have alleged happened back when it
happened and that's the real Point here
these crimes are alleged to have
happened over 20 years ago
between 2001 and 2003
and so even if you like me give these
women the benefit of the doubt you don't
think that they're intentionally lying
you assume that virtually everyone in
Hollywood is a complete degenerate so
you assume that maybe Danny Masterson
did get up to this stuff in his past if
you're going to be all the way on the
side of the accusers here even still you
probably like me have a a sense that
this is not just that there's something
unjust about this sentence to Danny
Masterson in the year of Our Lord 2023
for 30 years in prison
for crimes that were alleged to have
happened over 20 years ago why
because we just feel that if
if a crime is committed against you you
should you should bring charges in a
timely manner that's why we have things
like statutes of limitations
but in this case there's no more statute
of limitations
why is that well because earlier this
year in January of 2023 La got rid of
the statute of limitations on rape
and La did that because of the metoo
movement and the time's up movement and
the facade of of girl power that the
sexual predators who run Los Angeles are
going to permit to exist for a little
bit of time before they go back to just
committing all of the same crimes that
they've been committing for for decades
for like a century now
that's what this is about and statutes
of limitations are good what the what
the me too times up people will say is
statutes of limitations are awful
because they silence the survivors of
sexual assault
statutes of limitations protect the
rights of everybody
the reason we have them is because 20
years later
evidence is going to be lost
evidence is going to be
suspect
memories are going to be foggy
I could sincerely believe that something
happened 20 years ago and sometimes I do
I'll say I know that this happened 20
years ago and then a friend of mine with
whom I had shared that experience will
say oh no Michael you just
misremembering that I mean that could
happen for something that happened five
or ten years ago people's memories are
not reliable especially over that long
period of time so that's the first issue
is the statute of limitations thing
because they just got rid of it
it just seems unjust even if Danny
Masterson did
precisely or even approximately what
they're accusing him of doing
it's just something seems wrong about
that system right now go to
geniusell.com Knowles as you might know
we were all big fans of our friends over
at genucel in part because of that
founder who's a Coptic Christian from
Egypt who fled for the American dream
and largely just for how great the
product is don't take my word for it
Ella from Rockford says quote I have
both age and acne spots and this stuff
is actually fading both of them this
Serum is worth every penny Ella is
raving about the famous Dark Spot
Corrector from genucel a must-have after
months of record heat and humidity
sunspots brown spots discoloration even
red inflamed patches all disappear in
front of your very eyes and here's the
geniusell amazing guarantee you will see
results on day one or your money back so
take advantage of geniusell's most
popular package which now includes the
Dark Spot Corrector plus the classic
genius cell eyes and puffiness treatment
and immediate effects all about 77 0 off
so that you can try the best skincare in
the world for yourself completely
risk-free it is very simple
geniusell.com start looking years even
decades younger tomorrow say goodbye to
dark and liver spots bags and puffiness
under the eyes and crow's feet at
genucel.com Knowles that is genucel.com
Knowles
the second thing that this is about is
Scientology and one of the reasons I
believe the women or am inclined to
believe the women is
they did bring up this issue they did
bring up the crimes that allegedly
happened to them at the time but they
often didn't bring them up to law
enforcement or they didn't bring them up
directly to law enforcement they first
brought them up to Scientology because
they're all scientologists so they're
part of this cult and in this cult they
say don't ever go to the police about
anything just come to us which is
typical of Cults and and so these women
went to the Scientology ethics officers
and they said hey this guy raped me or
at the very least took advantage of me
or assaulted me or or something in
between and the ethics officer said yeah
well he's big and famous and important
so keep your mouth shut
and then they did in some cases the
women kept dating Masterson they kept
showing up to his house they could so
that is not to say that he didn't commit
some egregious act against them or that
he didn't even commit a crime against
them but it is to say
you play stupid games you get stupid
prizes I guess if you decide to put your
your Justice your experience of Justice
into the hands of Ethics officers in
occult well things probably aren't going
to work out in a very just way
if you continue to date someone after
you allege that they commit a terrible
crime against you people are going to
raise an eyebrow or maybe be a little
bit skeptical of your claims especially
if those claims come out decades later
and what is this really about it's not
even just about a Scientology it's about
Hollywood
this is how Hollywood operates
talked about this earlier in the week
Hollywood as a particularly egregious
example of the whole liberal
establishment operates in a way that is
kind of outside the law certainly
outside the moral laws often outside of
the civil law where you will be
encouraged to engage in really depraved
degrading things especially weird sex
stuff
and then
it just kind of goes away for a while
until it doesn't until it's convenient
until you're no longer useful to them or
until it's convenient to throw you under
the bus as an offering to the wolves and
that's what they'll do to you
nobody comes out of this
looking particularly good
uh I think that's generally true of
Hollywood and it's generally true of our
liberal culture but the problem here is
not going to be resolved just by
throwing Danny Masterson in prison
the problem is going to be resolved by
working and and correcting the entire
structures of Justice which have a
cultural component in the behavior and
Norms of Hollywood which have a
political component in the way that our
justice system works which is quite
unjust these days and It ultimately has
a theological component
in the Toleration of weirdo Cults like
this that victimize women
according to many many reports this is
this is what is inescapable
and it it's a problem that affects our
entire political order
all politics ultimately comes down to
religion Cardinal Manning put this well
he said all human conflict ultimately is
theological there never has been and
never can be a state that is divorced
from religion and Theological matters
because politics is about how we all
live together it has to do with laws and
ultimately laws come down to the moral
law and ultimately it comes down to the
question of the author of the moral law
politics has to do with people comes
down to the question of anthropology and
it has the comes down to the question of
who is man in whose image are we made
it it has to do with
ultimately
God because God is the author and
sustainer of all things and as long as
we keep
putting off the question and we say oh
God has nothing to do with Society we're
going to totally divorce Church from
State we don't more morality is just
socially constructed whatever then
weirdo Cults are going to continue to
prey on people and uh tyrannical
political leaders are going to continue
to flout
the the moral law and people are going
to continue to act in a way
it's very very
bad boy what a great clip that was now
hold on
you gotta ring that Bell subscribe to
the Michael null Show podcast see you
next time